so you turn 50 this year right or you
just turned 50 it's so interesting to me
that people can't project or understand
where the markets moving aka in this
scenario that we as 50 year olds I'm 40
but us 50 year olds are going to live
dramatically longer and healthier than
your parents and grandparents generation
so you sit here at 50 and as a child
what you grew up with you start
realizing like ooh where am I in my life
middle tail-end middle and so many of
your entrepreneurial and just life
ambitions start to window you start
settling in - this is my life this is
how it played out I could have I should
have and what I wish is that you know
what why am I making this video I'm
probably making it for my 50 year old
self so hey Garry 15 Oh some yeah you
step here you know what I hope to
accomplish with this one piece of
content is to inspire 1 49 50 51 year
old to understand you have a lot more
time than you think it is super
appropriate for you to start that
business that you've always wanted right
now it is actually quite practical you
probably actually have a much deeper
understanding of what to do to be
successful than the average 25 year old
that's rolling into my office looking
for dollars to start their business
because they've got an idea if I could
if I could just take the energy in my
heart to deploy it into so many people's
brains to understand how much time how
much time is still left in your life to
do your thing that would make me very
happy
um that would make me so happy because I
do believe as I'm spending a lot of time
may be affected by my last 15 20
hangouts with such age group individuals
way too many people are starting to plot
their exit their unwind and I'm like
Jesus you may have 50 that's right with
modern medicine you may have 50 more
good years of executing 40 for sure I
really think you know not gonna would so
many of you watching this have 40
folding years think back to when you
were 10 from that moment until right now
all that life you've got on the back end
and people are trying to wind down and
figure out how they're gonna slow it
down or wrap it up
[ __ ] wrapping it up man start it up
you're just 50